Now, we can solve for the acceleration of block 1.
Well, the acceleration is going to be caused by how much bigger this force is in this force or FT - m₁g
and that's going to equal m₁  a₁.
Now, the problem is we can't just go and solve this for a₁, not yet anyways.
This equation has two unknowns, the a₁ and the tension.
One equation will never be able to solve for two unknowns.
Maybe we can get more information by analyzing the second block. Well, let's do the diagram.
And before we go any further,
I'm going to move this equation over here to emphasize that the blank is at block 1.
Now, previously we showed the FT is bigger than m₁g since it's accelerating that way.
Well, m₂ we know must be accelerating this way, so m₂g must be bigger than FT
I've crossover an important point here--is this FT here the same as this FT here?
and the answer is yes, it is.
A rope always maintains the same tension throughout.
Maybe you prove it to yourself by trying to think about what would happen
if somehow the rope's tension change.
What would happen at the boundary point where the tension change?
That's something you should talk about in the forums.
Well, now the force doing the acceleration is how much bigger m₂g is over FT
and we can write a very similar equation m₂g - FT = m₂a₂, net force = mass  acceleration,
and once again we have two unknowns, a₂ and FT, well that consist a total of three unknowns,
FT, a₁, and a₂.
Two equations can never solve three unknowns, but hey, I realized something,
these blocks are connected by a string.
Any motion downwards from this guy has to correspond to motion upwards from this guy.
That means this acceleration has to be identical to this one.
We've done a little strange here what we called acceleration on this side,
positive when it's up, and on this side, positive when it's down,
but that's okay, we can do that.
So, now instead of the a₁ and a₂, I can just write a.
We're almost there--we're almost at something very cool
because now we only have two unknowns and two equations can solve two unknowns.